the countdown is on thursday evening las
vegas will celebrate the grand opening
of resorts world
it will be the first all-new property on
the strip in more than a decade
hector mejia updates us on how things
are going before doors officially open
the clock is ticking and there is no
time to waste brand new sidewalk right
behind us and down in the distance we
have crews
working on the last minute finishing
touches before this officially opens
the mega property is planning a grand
party
and once it opens this will be the
hottest place to check out this summer
the price tag to build 4.3 billion
dollars
it'll have quite the amenities from the
casino to the clubs
plus a five acre pool complex
3500 rooms and suites crews have been
going at it since may of 2015.
recently we've seen landscaping go up
the giant screens plugged in
and on resorts world promises to
redefine
many things including gambling it will
become the first casino in town to offer
cashless gambling at slots and table
games
and for the foodies over 40 food and
beverage options
the property is adding to the
entertainment capital of the world
with a concert venue large enough for
5 000 people the property is also
bringing more people to this
end of the strip where we still see lane
reductions along las vegas boulevard in
front of resorts world
the county working on a separate project
and they said they're working to reopen
lanes by the end of the week hector
mejia reporting
8 news now ongoing road construction in
front of resorts world will not be
completed in time for this thursday's
opening so to help alleviate the traffic
headache
clark county says there will be some
changes if you are headed southbound on
las vegas boulevard
there will be no lane closures in front
of resorts world
two lanes will be open between sahara
and spring mountain
heading northbound there will also be at
least two lanes open